So, how do you build one? Well that starts with the construction event that I briefly mentioned earlier
So what is the construction event again just to just to cover it?
Well, it's an event that we use to spawn rig elements during the preparation phase of the control rig graph
And what does this mean? So
this means that we use this event before the forwards or backwards solve logic to
spawn any of our rig elements like controls or bones or nulls and
It's an event that only runs once at the start of the control rig logic
Now it doesn't just spawn the rig elements
but we can also use it to set the initial positions of any of the rig elements that we're spawning or creating and
initialize variables update the hierarchy and
Importantly import the skeleton of the mesh that we're assigning this control rig to
Because as I said before if you were to make any changes to your skeleton the fact that you're
importing the skeleton on the construction event will pick up any of those changes that have been made and
This is essentially the main tool that allows you to procedurally build a control rig
And without this without the construction event, none of it would be possible
Taking a look at some of the common nodes and functions that you'd use at the construction event here
We have the spawn transform control node
Now this allows you to
spawn a control and set its position and
Determine what the control actually looks like so the scale of it the shape of it that kind of thing
So you could use this to spawn several different controls all at once with all of the same settings
If you know what position that controls in and how the control looks so you're not having to
manually recreate each one and
multiple times
There's also the control stack at item function, which is a function that's pre-built into the engine that is
comprised of other procedural rigging nodes like the spawn node
metadata and other string operator nodes and
Its function is similar to that of the spawn transform control node, but with a bit more functionality
So it allows you to add nulls above and below the control that you're spawning
To add the extra level of control within the hierarchy if you need that
You can also add secondary controls as children of the control that you're spawning
And it's a little easier to do things like rename your controls with the the built-in naming options
Tags are also a new concept with procedural rigging
So they allow you to tag parts of the rig with custom names to access in the rig logic and make updates to many
Parts at once so you could tag all of the bones with the name bone or all of the controls with the name control
for example and
Effect all of those things at once by just finding the items with that tag
Now it's a little bit like setting a variable to access in other parts of the rig logic later
You also have the ability to set metadata on elements within the rig
So storing data on things like controls or bones or nulls
Now this is similar to tagging but think of it more like a big container that can hold multiple data types
Unlike just storing a name with the tag
So the value of the metadata that you're setting includes the name as well as the type of element for that particular part of the rig
so you can just do a bit more with the information and
it's intended to pass data from the construction event to the forwards or backwards solve logic and
There's also the concat or concatenate node and this is useful for adding a suffix to the name of things and
We'll be using this to name our controls
To help us differentiate the names of our controls and our bones as well as build the hierarchy of our rig
We're going to be building a simple FK rig for our character
That you'll be able to use and set up for any of your own skeletal meshes in your own projects
Now, let's take a look at some of the nodes that we're going to be using for this setup
Now some of them you may have used before when you're creating your control rigs
But some of them are specifically intended to be used with the construction event
So it's unlikely you've come into contact with them before but the more of the the more traditional modes and functions
We're going to be using the item name search node now that allows us to essentially
Search for all of the elements within the rig that contain a particular name or even partial name
And this will allow us to grab lots of information at once to use to generate some controls
Now we'll also use the get transform node
which just allows us to get the transform of a particular element of the rig and
We'll use this information to set the transforms of our controls
Then we'll use the get parent node and this just allows us to search up the chain and find the parent of a particular
Item which we'll use to set up our hierarchy and then the concat node
Which is just going to help us name our controls and a couple of functions that we'll be using are the FK chain function
which is going to connect our controls and our bones together so the controls can drive the movement of the bones and
the colorize controls function
Which allows us to essentially automatically color our controls based on their position
Now some nodes that you may not recognize or at least may not have used before if you haven't worked with procedural rigging yet
Are the import skeleton node now
This is exactly what what you think it would be so it imports the skeleton into the control rig hierarchy
And it's great for picking up any changes that might have happened to the skeleton like you've added or remove bones for example
Or it's great for importing a different skeleton when you're using this rig on a different character
We'll also use the spawn control node to spawn all of our controls and set their initial positions and
We'll use the add tag and find items with tag nodes for our bones and our controls
So we'll tag our bones or tag our controls and we use the information in the FK chain function later on and then lastly
We'll take a look at the control stack at item function
just so we can see a different way of spawning the controls and see some benefits of the
Well of this function versus the spawn control node